Fifty bucks and 2000 articles
on automotive history. The next time the college
sponsors electro program on the auto industry
I think we're going to keep him on our shortlist.
The title of his presentation today is "Churchill
in His Own Words." Please welcome Richard
Langworth.
Thank you, Richard.
Richard: Is Larry here?
Yes.
Richard: I want to be sure of this.
Thank you for this kind introduction I learned
so much about myself, I'm very impressed,
I hope you are too.
I'd like to thank Dr. Arnn for all of his
hard work in starting this thing off but not
so much for his quotes. He said today ... He's
just asked me for this, that if you keep a
dog you don't have to bark yourself, meaning
Andrew and me. While we're having lunch I
looked this up in a research resource tool
that we're creating which I spoke to about
yesterday in which we're trying to put all
of the words in the Churchill Cannon into
easily searchable digital form, and it's not
there.
I'm not sure where he got it but I aim to
find out, but there is a good dog quote and
maybe you'd like to hear what he really said.
You know this one anyway.
Speaker 3: [Inaudible 00:01:31].
Richard: Sorry?
Speaker 3: [Inaudible 00:01:33].
Richard: The Axminster [inaudible 00:01:43]?
You tell me later.
Speaker 3: He says my quote is true.
Richard: Well, Churchill was invited to the
departure party for Herr von Ribbentrop as
he was leaving his ambassadorial post to go
back to Berlin to do something more important,
which happened to fall on the day Hitler was
invading the Rhineland. Churchill wondered
why the government had bothered to invite
him and he said, "I thought that if they didn't
bark themselves they wanted the Germans to
know they did have a dog who did bark and
might bite."
I'd like to give you a picture about where
Winston Churchill stands in the public mind
today as we embark on the Churchill Project
at Hillsdale College as he moves from a figure
familiar to many to a figure for the ages.
The digital age tends to skew the broad image
of Churchill, who he was, what he stood for.
It is up to us who study, know, and appreciate
him to follow his daughter Mary's wish to
keep the memory green and the record accurate.
[Inaudible 00:02:59] very shortly because
I was given only 20 minutes and I've only
overstepped my bounds for another 20 minutes.
I'll try to be very concise and speak very
briefly about our difficulties and our assets
in educating people about Churchill, and then
try to give you a net assessment of the two.
Let's start with the bad news, for all too
many young people today history turns on the
internet where Churchill fades into the blue
distance of the Middle Ages. Thousands Google
Churchill, half a billion play Star Craft.
It's not always easy to comprehend, many are
distracted from the truth by sensationalist
fantasy and that's a problem because it tends
to overwhelm what Churchill teaches us about
life and liberty, about the nature of man
and free institutions.
This is important because perhaps more now
than since Churchill's times our liberties
are again under assault, not from anything
like he had to face but from more insidious
forces, some of them internal. For example
Churchill taught and wrote a good deal about
balancing a proper concern for the general
welfare with the power of the state. He has
advice worth contemplating.
Dr. Arnn, as he's already told you has just
written a book about this, Churchill's Trial,
out this year. He hired Doc Jeffrey, and me
to bet it and nitpick it, which we did and
as a result he had to rewrite the entire book.
It's a far better product now than it was
when it started, and thank you Doc Jeffrey,
but the thoughtful, philosophic, pragmatic
Churchill was often buried in a bubbling digital
soup in which to capture your attention he's
made to say or do anything from gassing a
rocky tribesman to firebombing Dresden.
Putting words in his mouth is a popular pastime.
Quotations maven Nigel Rees says, "If you
don't know the author of a choice remark,
credit it to Churchill, Einstein, Lincoln,
or Martin Luther King. Everyone will be impressed
and they all said so much that nobody will
know the difference."
Churchill's name elicits 20 to 40 million
Google hits depending on where you enter it,
or when you enter it, many are bizarre accusations
which demand categorial denial such as Churchill
wanted to euthanize the feeble-minded. He
knew in advance about Pearl Harbor but kept
quiet so as to drag the Americans into the
war. He exacerbated the Bengal Famine in 1943.
He elect Coventry Burn to protect his secret
intelligence, an actor read his speeches,
he issued sailing orders that sank the Lusitania.
He was bipolar and an alcoholic. He knew but
did nothing about the Holocaust.
Here is my current favorite which was sent
to my website, we welcome all points of view,
"There are plenty more occasions recorded
throughout history where this wicked old [inaudible
00:06:11] allowed his true persona to be revealed."
If this is not enough to depress you, and
I see very few suicides in the room at the
moment let me make it easier for those of
you who are already inclined in this direction,
especially after Mr. Krauthammer's talk and
sample some of the sheer ignorance generated
by a lot of quality electronic [inaudible
00:06:34] corner.
Much of what's out there is so poorly edited
or bedded that it threatens to overwhelm what
matters, some of it even relegates our man
into legend. A recent survey in the UK reveal
that 1 in 5 school children think Churchill
was a mythical figure like King Arthur or
James Bond. Indeed I think more of them think
007 was real than Sir Winston. When his true
persona does emerge [inaudible 00:07:03] we
are often baffled by it because they lack
instruction in Churchillian ways.
"How," one web poster asked, "Could this great
man save Erwin Rommel, the commander of the
Afrika Korp?" "We have a very daring and skillful
opponent against us, and may I say across
the havoc of war a great general." Now you
and I know the reason which is that with Churchill
what you saw was what you got. He never hid
his admiration for fine qualities even among
enemies, but taken out of context, as it often
is, that remark upsets those who know only
which side Rommel was on. At least I hope
they know which side he was on.
I'd just written a book Churchill's Lost Years,
about the 1930's investigating his claim that
World War II was preventable. It took a chapter
to show how those in-charge … those who
charge, that he once praised Hitler that they
just can't attach him to the context of his
words. I surely hope that he was right about
Hitler from the start. Dead right. That leads
us to another problem, the view of Churchill
as a one-dimensional figure of World War II.
Even some who profess to admire him see him
only in terms of 1940.
Sir Martin Gilbert asked to summarize Churchill
in one sentence said nothing about blood,
toil, tears, and sweat. Sir Martin said, "He
was a great humanitarian who was himself distressed
that the accidents of history gave him his
greatest power at a time when everything had
to be focused on defending the country from
destruction rather than achieving his goals
of a fair society."
The problem I think is that many people will
simply believe anything. You can probably
find more pure rubbish about Churchill online
now than all the hypocritical books written
about him in the last century.
Churchill's virtues like his faults were on
a grand scale but the virtues extended out
way are false. This is our challenge as educated
people to pound home those virtues. Churchill
once told the future King Edward VIII, "If
you have an important point to make don't
try to be subtle or clever, use a pile driver,
hit the plank once, then come back and hit
it again, and then hit it a third time." The
King certainly took that advice as he pounded
on his choice of wife so well that he had
to abdicate.
But now I hope you are all in despair so now
is the time to go from the bad news to the
not-so-bad-news. The Israeli scholar Daniel
Schriften likes to tell about a member of
the Poland Bureau in Bresner’s time during
the great Russo-Chinese rivalries saying,
"Comrades, I have bad news and good news.
First the bad news, the Chinese have landed
on the moon. Now the good news, all of them."
I wish I had something that would be equivalent
to this [inaudible 00:10:13], but I don't
so let's go on to the not so bad news.
In the film Stand Up Guys, a character played
by Al Pacino makes an arresting observation,
"You really die twice," he says, "First when
the last breath leaves your body, and second
when the last person who knew you says your
name for the final time." By that standard
we may conclude that Winston Churchill is
immortal, at least for now. 50 years since
his death those who knew him have dwindled
to a handful and yet his name is still all
over the news.
When the last person who knew him says his
name for the last time Churchill will live
on like Washington, Lincoln, the two Roosevelt's,
but even among those immortals it is Churchill
who dominates the news, the media. "Why?"
I asked the historian David Dilks, the biographer
Neville Chamberlain, we know no one's agree
but no one is a better judge. "Churchill,"
David Dilks said, "Brought to public life
valor of the highest order, not the unthinking
resolution of one blind to danger but the
deliberate courage of a man who appreciates
it, apprehends it all too well." To that he
added what is almost as rare in high politics,
“constructive imagination."
Will he remain immortal 50 years from now?
I don't know, probably yes. I don't know what
will happen in the next 50 years. You'll have
to ask Dr. Arnn, he'll still be in office
and I'm sure he'll give you a very good answer,
but in terms of the present in the next generation
Churchill's immortality is something over
which we may feel confident.
The next piece of not-so-bad-news is that
while ignorance is pervasive it is not all
pervasive through the work of Hillsdale College,
the National Churchill Museum, the Churchill
Center, the Churchill War Rooms, the Churchill
Archives Center and others, the truth is being
disseminated. Public figures are cagey now
when they quote Churchill. Sometimes they
qualify their quotes or come to us even to
see if they're true.
Senator John Warner of Virginia quoted the
famous but non-verified Churchillism, "Americans
will always do the right thing, after all
of the possibilities are exhausted." He quickly
added that, "Good authority suggests Churchill
didn't say this, but if not he should have."
Fair enough, it's almost too good for him
not to have said it.
The columnist George Will mentioned the genuine
red herring, "The greatest argument against
democracy is a five-minute conversation with
the average voter." Have you heard that one?
It's all over the web. Many admitted that
Churchill probably never said this at all.
Correct. He had more respect than that for
the average voter.
At the bottom of all the tributes paid to
democracy he said, "It's the little man walking
into the little booth with a little pencil,
making a little cross on a little bit of paper."
We still vote that way in New Hampshire. "No
amount of rhetoric or voluminous discussion,"
Churchill said, "Can possibly diminish the
overwhelming importance of that point." Of
course he assumed the little man was carrying
a valid form of voter ID.
Let me demonstrate how it's possible to counteract
innuendo and falsehood with Churchill in his
own words. He was no fan of India's Congress
Party and he said very rude things about Mr.
Gandhi. He will repeat it today. I don't have
to repeat them again. Yet in 1935 after the
government of India act had passed over his
opposition he sent this message, "Tell Mr.
Gandhi to use the powers that are offered
and make the thing a success. You have got
the things now make a success, and if you
do I will advocate you getting much more."
Mr. Gandhi has gone very high in my esteem
since he stood up for the untouchables. Now
those who quote Churchill on Gandhi never
quote Gandhi on Churchill. Here is what the
Mahatma replied through Mr. [inaudible 00:14:21]
Dr. Arnn discussed earlier. "I have got a
good recollection of Mr. Churchill when he's
in the Colonial Office, and somehow or rather
since then I have held the opinion that I
can always rely on his sympathy and goodwill."
Gandhi remembered that Churchill stood up
for the rights of the South African Indian
Minority, in 1906, 25 years before when he
was Assistant Secretary for the Colonies.
“I was put on to this by a fair-minded Indian
who reminded me that Hitler had rather different
things in mind for India than the old British
Raj.” A reporter wrote this in the Weekly
Standard during a minor media flop last year
about how furious Churchill would be over
a statue of Gandhi being raised near his in
Parliament Square. I said Churchill would
be fine with it. He'd be pleased that India
has become the world's largest parliamentary
democracy.
What do we draw from all these? That Churchill
was, William Manchester wrote, "Always had
second and third thoughts, and they usually
improve as he went along. It was part of his
pattern of response to any political issue,
that while his early reactions were often
emotional and even unworthy of him they were
usually succeeded by reason and generosity."
In the 1930's when he was warning about Nazi
Germany, Churchill joked about the optimist
and the pessimist. The optimist he said was
a man who did not mind what happened so long
as it didn't happen to him. The pessimist
was a man who lived with the optimist. Now
on preserving Churchill's legacy the question
we must answer is not whether we are optimist
or pessimist but the question of net assessment,
are we making progress or not?
There are at least five reasons to believe
we are making progress. First is Churchill
himself, he's reliable. You can always count
on his high-mindedness. Martin Gilbert struck
me when he said, "Sometimes I might find that
he was adopting views with which I disagreed
but I always knew that there would be nothing
to cause me to think how shocking, how appalling,
and how many great figures can we say that?"
Second, Churchill hangs around, however profound
the thoughts and decisive the acts of great
personages their relevance tends to diminish
with time. David Dilks says, "For Churchill
the process is somewhat postponed for in the
long life he decided much and influenced more."
Third is Hillsdale College's Churchill Project
which unites and offers two unique resources.
Sir Martin Gilbert's Churchill favorites and
the 10 million word official biography are
coupled to Hillsdale established skills in
scholarly outreach. You heard about this yesterday
so I won't re-describe it, except to say we
welcome your thoughts and input.
Fourth, you may consider this odd but let's
face it, we're all a bit odd. Churchill was
fun to study. He's a keen judge of people
with a droll sense of humor. He smiles when
he fights. He represents many sides to many
questions.
The historian Paul Addison says, "Since history
never repeats itself the policies that Churchill
adopted do not provide ready-made solutions
today but his writings and speeches are full
of reflections and philosophy that offer food
for thought, and it's rare to discover in
the archives the reflections of a politician
on the nature of men." That is something Hillsdale
has considered since its founding.
As Dr. Arnn explains, "We were founded as
every old Liberal Arts College was founded,
to study the nature of men, his place in the
order of creation." This work much more than
any contemporary political question is the
heart and work of a college and its main substance.
Fifth and the last, there's always something
new to learn. A [inaudible 00:18:27] once
lamented to Martin Gilbert, "Why you've scarcely
told 10% of the Churchill story?" Martin replied,
"Really, that much?" Here is an example and
a challenge and that it shows Churchill wasn't
always right. Writing my book on the 1930's
I was repeatedly warned by scholars and I
will pass this warning on now to students,
don't be an innocent reader of The Gathering
Storm, ominous warning. It's a great read.
It certainly hooked me but it's not always
the absolute authority. Churchill said, "This
is my case, not history, this is my case."
Here is proof which teaches us much about
the persona of Winston Churchill. It's a damning
entry in the Index under Prime Minister Stanley
Baldwin. "Confesses to putting party before
country." This refers to a 1936 speech in
which Baldwin said, "Supposing I had gone
for the country and said that Germany was
rearming and that we must rearm, does anybody
think that this specific democracy would rally
to that cry at that moment? I cannot think
of anything that would have made the loss
of the election, from my point of view more
certain."
The next day Churchill wrote a friend, "I
have never heard such a squalid confession
from a public man as Baldwin offered us yesterday,"
and he never forgot it. In The Gathering Storm
he wrote that for Baldwin to avow he had not
done his duty in regard to national safety
because he was afraid of losing the election.
[Inaudible 00:19:59] quote, "Indecency."
For many years there after it was accepted
that Baldwin had put politics before country
but Churchill had done Baldwin an injustice.
He quoted him selectively, omitting exculpatory
passages, in fact Baldwin statement referred
to 1933-34 when the country was more pacifist,
and Churchill was both that same day admitted
that Baldwin had fought the 1935 election
on rearmament. Thus Churchill or an editorial
assistant, I think it was his son Randolph
who edited his speeches from which this was
derived, "Unfairly edited Baldwin's defense
of himself," but the more interesting thing
I found in researching this was, "So what?
Baldwin is still not wholly vindicated."
To appreciate this I had to read the entire
passage, enhance art with parliamentary debates
from Churchill's speech, which also doesn't
appear in The Gathering Storm. He not only
edited the Prime Minister, he edited himself.
Churchill said that while Baldwin had stressed
rearmament in the 1935 campaign, he also said
in the same campaign, "There will be no great
armaments and you can't have it both ways.
You can't build an air force equal to Germany's
without great new armaments."
Baldwin not only admitted that, had the election
occurred earlier he would not have mentioned
rearmament because he would have lost. He
also gave mixed messages in the actual election
campaign. His rather like Senator Kerry saying
he was for the Iraq war before he was against
it, or some of the new candidates for president,
three of which I thought were pretty interesting
guys changing their pronouncements over the
last five years in a matter of hours. One
of them changed his position on immigration,
another on foreign aid, and the third on the
ethanol subsidy.
Now it doesn't matter what I think or you
think of the ethanol subsidy, I have a 53
Studebaker I can tell you all about the ethanol
subsidy but the point is that you don't win
elections by reversing your principles. The
difference in state craft between Baldwin
and Churchill is the duty of a leader in a
free society. Is it the duty of a leader in
a free society to take action that though
to his mind right and necessary jeopardizes
his political survival or back away and hope
the electric will come around a little later?
Churchill's ringing declaration that same
year stands in some contrast to what Baldwin
said. "I would endure with patience the roar
of exultation that would go up when I was
proved wrong because it would lift a load
off my heart. What does it matter who gets
exposed or discomfited? If the country is
safe who cares for individual politicians
in or out of office?" That's Winston Churchill
uncompromised even with himself.
Here's another example of how you can learn
new things by accident. A colleague has said,
"Churchill personally seen the Dardanelles
before those twin World War I tragedies, the
Dardanelles and Gallipoli Campaigns. You've
probably heard of the plan Churchill wanted
to sail asleep through the straits across
the Sea of Marmara, to fear off Constantinople
and cower the Turks into surrender, relieving
the Russians who were bottled up in the Black
Sea.
It was his alternative too, as he told the
Prime Minister, "Chewing barbwire in Flanders."
The short answer was, "Yes, he had seen the
Dardanelles before it happened, before the
invasion." The long answer sheds fresh light
on his character. I quickly found that Churchill
visited Turkey in 1910 on a two month’s
cruise of Asia Minor, which brought him to
Constantinople ergo he obviously sails through
the Dardanelles, stopping at Smirnoff I discovered
he sallied forth on a side trip into Turkey
riding rather incongruously for a minister
of the crown in an iron seat welded to the
caricature of a locomotive.
Now it's impossible to conceive of his colleagues
like Lloyd George or Asquith riding the rails
on a caricature. Reflecting on his travels
Churchill wrote the Foreign Secretary Sir
Edward Gray, "The only view I have formed
about this part of the world of ruined civilizations
and harshly jumbled races is this, why can't
England and Germany come together in strong
action and for general advantage?"
Pursuing the answer to a simple question I
stumbled on another example of Churchill's
character, his impulse to seek coalitions
and understanding among the great powers.
All the more interesting he said this in 1910,
before the great Anglo-German naval rivalry
that helped lead to World War I, yet somehow
he could visualize the dangers ahead. Despite
many superficial claims that Churchill was
the chief drum beater for World War I his
impulses were quite the opposite. This story
belongs in our catalog of his many efforts
to preserve the peace.
In our net assessment of where Churchill stands
today I think we can say with Professor [Inaudible
00:25:43] we have a problem but not a dilemma.
It's a problem because the amount of sheer
nonsense hoisted on us daily. Why is it not
a dilemma? Because we know what to do about
it. To paraphrase one of Churchill's famous
expressions, "We have the tools to finish
the job."
"You think he was a genius," one critic protested.
Well, perhaps if we accept one famous definition
of genius, the capacity for taking infinite
pains, Churchill strolled as he said to Neville
Chamberlain, "According to his lights, to
the utmost of his capacity and authority,
which were powerful to save the world from
awful devastating struggle. Once that struggle
was upon him he didn't win it, that was not
in his power. What we did was not lose it."
He is said to have suffered from manic depression,
another fallacy. "The things he went through
would depress anybody," his daughter used
to day. My own description of him is optimistic
realist, especially about humanity. We've
heard this before in this conference, "The
same imperfect being," he wrote, "Presented
by science were increasingly potent and dangerous
toys, yet man spirit has from the earliest
dawn of history shown itself upon occasion
capable of mounting to a sublime."
Professor John Marini speaking at Hillsdale
about the films of Frank Capra, said that
in later life, "Capra understood that Hollywood
would be changing because the culture in society
had begun the change. The historical and personal
categories of class and race have become political,
and self-expression and self-indulgence have
replaced those civic virtues that require
self-restraint."
Churchill wrote long before World War II,
and this is what the Marini put me on to,
“Democratic governments drift along the
line of least resistance taking short views,
paying their way with sops and dulls and smoothing
their path with pleasant sounding platitudes.”
One wonders what Capra and Churchill would
say today. Perhaps it is well we don't know."
"Churchill was indeed a noble spirit," Martin
Gilbert wrote, "Sustained in his long life
by a faith and the capacity of man to live
in peace, to seek prosperity, and to ward
off threats and dangers by his own exertions.
His love of country, his sense of fair play,
his hopes for the human race were matched
by formidable powers of work and thought,
vision and foresight. His path had often been
dogged by controversy, disappointment and
abuse but these had never deflected him from
his sense of duty and his faith in the British
people, and to that I would add the American
people.
The day before he retired Sir Winston told
some of his ministers, "Never be separated
from the Americans." Nowadays he might advise
the Americans never to be separated from their
friends and to be wary of avowed enemies.”
Free people in every part of the world are
treading no smooth or easy roads, yet it cannot
be worse than others we've traveled in the
past. "It may well be," Churchill said, "That
the most glorious chapters of our history
are yet to be written. We ought to rejoice
at the responsibilities with which destiny
has honored us and be proud that we are guardians
of our country in an age when her life is
at stake." Thank you.
Speaker 4: Thank you Mr. Langworth. Now we
have some time for a few questions. If you
have a question please raise your hand and
one of us will bring a mic to you.
Speaker 5: Richard, among adult readers -
Richard: Where are you?
Speaker 5: Who are well-educated and curious
-
Richard: Where are you? I see, I see what
[inaudible 00:30:08]. Sorry.
Speaker 5: Among adult readers who are well-educated
and curious but had never been exposed to
the Cannon of Churchill, if they were to read
one book, which should it be? Before you respond
however, if they said they'd read more than
one which would you suggest should be the
first one?
Richard: Did you mean by him or about him?
Speaker 5: By him.
Richard: By him, My Early Life every time,
right Barry? Where's Barry? Barry, he said
it earlier. My Early Life because it captivates
this tremendous personality building and it's
written in a very self-deprecating way really.
His wonderful descriptions, his encounters
with mathematics he likens to dark dungeons
with goblins and demons. With science he went
into a strange cargo of science and acoustics
and further dim [inaudible 00:31:07] lighted
by sulfurous fires were refuted to contain
a dragon called the differential calculus,
but I have never met any of these monsters
since. He was never very good at mathematics.
My Early Life first, then second The Gathering
Storm, and even though I said it, don't be
an innocent reader, it is his case, he admitted
it was, it's not history. People say Churchill's
history of the Second World War, not a history.
It's his personal reflections.
General Alan Brooke ... Lord Alan Brooke complained
that, "Winston's published all of his directives
and letters to me but he doesn't quote any
of my replies." Later on went on to record
in his diary some pretty tough letters written
late at night when he was tired and exasperated.
In his defense he would get letters, messages
from Churchill, "Pray ascertain for me the
soundings in the bay of Rio De Janeiro and
let me have this by tomorrow's post." No clue
what so ... Oh my God, is he thinking of invading
Brazil? But that was Alan Brooke and you have
to take it all with a grain of salt. Alan
Brooke was a great soldier, a brilliant man
and was frustrated working for this thunderbolt,
this tornado.
Those two books anyway, I think. If you can't
get ... The Gathering Storm is what started
me. It was 1965, Churchill's funeral was on
television. I was in my wife Barbara's cellar
in Staten Island, New York. I like the English
thing, mostly English cars and I saw this
and I said, "Wow this is quite a character.
I must read about him." I picked up The Gathering
Storm and the rest is history. I was hooked
but for a while I believed every word in it.
It's only about 99% true.
Any other questions. No? I can't see a thing.
Now I can see.
Speaker 6: Towards the beginning of your presentation
you were talking about the digital age and
its relation to Churchill and you seem to
kind of infer that the digital age seems to
be kind of bad for him and his legacy, and
I was wondering if the digital age is the
problem or if it's the integrity of the digital
age?
Richard: No, I think it's an expression of
a problem, without it where would we be? You
have ... Churchill knew this you have to march
on with progress and take it as it comes.
It's just that it is totally un-policed and
there are a lot of people that want to police
it, I'm not among them but we have tools to
fight back, as I said to counteract innuendo
and falsehood and we do it pretty well. You
can tell that in people quoting Churchill
in the media, they're a lot more careful than
they used to be.
There's still an awful lot about, "If I were
married to you I'd put poison in your coffee.
If I were married to you Lady Astor, I would
drink it." But you see, half the world now
knows that was Lord Birkenhead who was much
better off than [inaudible 00:34:32] Churchill
was. We are making progress. No, I don't feel
it's all a bad thing, it's just un-policed
and that's the problem with free speech.
Speaker 7: Do we have time for ...
Speaker 4: We have time for just one more
question.
Speaker 8: Why do you think that The World
Crisis hasn't gotten more exposure in terms
of Churchill's Cannon?
Richard: When I first ... After I read The
Gathering Storm I read all the other World
War II volumes. In My Early Life I wanted
to read The World Crisis which I think is
his best example of my case as he called it,
because it was written in the same way, it
was his defense. I look for an order, in those
days you had to do this un-digitally, finally
found it and the ordered the book, The Crisis
by Winston Churchill. It turned out to be
The Crisis … The Civil War novel by the
American Winston Churchill, who was a contemporary
and was so well-known in the early part of
the 20th Century that Winston S. Churchill
had to write him and apologize for the confusion
that had resulted from their names.
Barbara was saying the other day that we had
the pleasure of taking Lady Soames to the
Library of Dartmouth College where Winston
Churchill, the American’s papers where and
there was the letter from her father to the
American novelist. Mr. Winston Churchill presents
his compliments to Mr. Winston Churchill and
begs to discuss the subject of mutual concern.
The World Crisis had a long and happy print
run. It was still in print in the 1960's.
Griffin republished it after World War II.
I don't know what its press run is. Barry
you might know how many copies you sell of
it, but it hasn't had the coverage I think
simply because Second World War just eclipsed
the Great War, and it was fresh in everyone's
memory and it was so horrific in many ways.
Britons I think tend to put, like to put or
prefer to put the first World War out of their
memory because this decimated a generation.
I remember Alex DeCroce saying it was much
more worse than that because sometimes the
losses are much more greater than one intend,
but the second World War made Winston Churchill
a great man as we said earlier and that's
been the focus. I object to that because that
seems to be for some people the only focus.
You ask the average Churchill admirer and
they say 1940. They don't know about all the
other things and there's this huge trove of
stuff that we can get into that we find fascinating.
As Dr. Arnn said he spoke about things that
most politicians never even bothered to consider.
Does that answer your question?
Speaker 8: Yes, thank you.
Richard: Thank you.
Speaker 1: Thank you very much Richard. If
you are enjoying this program please consider
joining us on campus in October of this year
when we'll be sponsoring another lecture program
on Winston Churchill. Each of the college
sponsors four-week long lecture programs on
campus under the auspices of the Center for
Constructive Alternatives or CCA. These programs
consider range of topics related to the college’s
mission and core curriculum, they feature
a series of guest speakers and conclude with
a round table analysis of the week's lectures
by members of the college faculty, I guess
you could call it our version of the Fox All-stars.
Confirmed guest speakers for the Churchill's
CCA Pro -